[Музика]
привіт
неофіційно saberzadeh Браво meepo
Давос з проливів більше Малік аратаура
апостольство вода можливий офіційний клас
у гнізді муладхара anodyne колір всі
однокласники Гавани мій алкільний радикал який
час атакує
привіт хлопці прийшов час уроку англійської
моє ім'я  це Наталія лешка
давайте почнемо і я б хотів привітати
мого дуже дорогого гостя сьогодні привіт Ольга
привіт Наталія приємно познайомитися також приємно
познайомитися як ти сьогодні я добре
як ти я ідеальний класний тож
давайте на урок
ти готовий так давайте приєднуйся до нас тож
сьогодні ми продовжимо розмову про
літературу та читання у мене
до вас питання що ми читаємо так
молодець, а зараз я запитаю у Ольги Ольги
що ми читаємо щодня кожен день я
читаю все  Я можу зробити, я читаю
щось у пакетах добре, я читаю багато
книг і журналів в Інтернеті, звичайно,
новини, я читаю новини, іноді вони
засмучують, а якщо про літературу, я читаю
організації та читаю книги, тому що це
як  Джендрі так, Вірджинія Вулф,
це дійсно добре, це складно
читати, але мені це подобається, а також у мене є
Крісті, вона одна фонетична, що це
за книжки Агата Крісті,
це документальна література, добре,
детектив, так, так, давайте
подивимося на  подивіться мою кругову діаграму
, тому ми вже обговорювали,
що на наших уроках ми читаємо
веб-сайти коміксів, журнали, рекламу, оскільки
Ольга згадала, що вона читає
пакети, а також блокує газети та
електронні книги,
тож ви читаєте те саме чи інше, тож,
Ольга, ви можете сказати мені, що з  це
ти читаєш я не люблю читати блоги, ок
та електронні книги, це моє улюблене, тому що
коли мої діти лягають спати, це
можливість відкрити книгу в моєму
блокноті, і він читатиме добре в коміксах,
це не про мене, а про лату моєї дочки
вона любить комікси, це більше для підлітків
так, добре, журнали, які
мені подобаються, журнали зі зміненим стилем мають
велику колекцію з 1998 року, і я люблю
їх читати, добре, тому давайте створимо нашу власну
кругову діаграму,
щоб це було завданням для вас
подивіться, тому намалюйте велике коло та розділіть
його на різні частини, якщо ви подивитеся на
мою кругову діаграму, усі частини рівні, але
ви можете зробити їх коротшими, якщо ви не
розглядаєте багато електронних книг, наприклад, у
журналах чи газетах, або більше, якщо  ви
читайте більше, наприклад, для моєї кругової
діаграми книги будуть найбільшою
частиною, тому ми збираємося створити нашу кругову
діаграму з Ольгою, а ви створюйте з нами,
давайте візьмемо 15 секунд.
покажіть нам свою кругову діаграму, вибачте за
мій почерк, все добре, мій такий
самий, як ви бачите Наталія, я
сильно смержу, я буду читати багато книжок на
папері, також маю велику частину дитячих книжок, у
нас є гарна бібліотека вдома
електронні книги відіграють важливу роль у моєму
повсякденному житті добре, веб-сайти та новини
також дуже важливі для мене, особливо в
наш час молодці, дуже
дякую за це, давайте подивимося на мою
кругову діаграму, вона трохи інша, тому знову
ж таки найбільша частина – це папір  книги я
їх дуже люблю, тому e  книги не є великою частиною,
тому що я не люблю читати електронні книги,
тому що я піклуюся про свій зір, і
давайте подивимося на ці частини
журнали, це майже те саме, що книги,
газети, прислівники та блоги, знову
дуже маленька частина, щоб ви могли розповісти про
свій  кругова діаграма
скільки ви читаєте, дякую, то давайте
далі, це різні типи
книг, ви їх пам'ятаєте, ми
вже обговорювали, що тут було
кримінальний трилер так, Ольга, чи
пам'ятаєте ви які типи книг, які ви
вже згадували, детектив наукової літератури
Розділ оповідань поетичні романи добре, і,
можливо, ви можете порадити щось інше, так,
звичайно, так що наші діти вони для них це
урок номер три, тому ми
вже торкнулися цієї теми, тому якщо ви
подивитеся на літери, наприклад, як F
і T, хм, якщо ви  подумайте про жанр,
тож, ймовірно, фентезі так так, давайте
вгадаємо всі типи книг тут,
наприклад, ви згадали щось на
кшталт наукової так, це тут не
справжня фантастика, і я бачу
Біографія Litella тут так добре зроблено, і
цього досить, це досить складно,
так що це як головоломка, давайте розгадати
головоломку і
потроху подивіться на цей документ, так
Brava
документальна література, давайте повторимо ще раз
нехудожня література, велике дякую
що з цього приводу так, дуже дякую,
наукова фантастика і давайте повторимо ще раз
наукова фантастика, дякую, що з
цього приводу всім так,
в книгах Остін є історія кохання так, це так мило, тому
ми називаємо їх романтичним романом так, давайте
далі, я вже згадував про це
фентезі так, ти любиш читати фентезі,
але ні, я ненавиджу це
ага добре, вибачте, чи можу я сказати слово ненавиджу
так добре, ви можете висловити свою думку, не
хвилюйтеся, але як щодо вас, ви любите
читати фантастичні книги, добре, давайте далі,
що з цього приводу я  вибачте, я загубився, я
допоможу вам без турбот, єдині
літери, яких не вистачає, це OHS чи можете ви
вгадати жахи
так страшилки,
ймовірно, це нецікаво для вас, але
багато дітей та підлітків  люди, вони люблять читати
жахи, особливо хлопчики,
добре, давайте перейдемо до дівчини.
Браво біографія, а як щодо цих
пригод Браво,
то давайте скажемо разом пригодницька
пригода, дякую, що з цього приводу я
втратив, я допоможу вам, цей світ
складається з двох частин  перший - це
cm кримінальний так, а другий -
кримінальний трилер Cyrilla Srila кримінальний трилер О,
наприклад, книги Агати Крісті також можуть бути
кримінальними трилерами, а Артур
Конан Дойл так, Браво, тож давайте перейдемо до
того, що про це ви вже
згадували в різних історіях сьогодні
класичний класик які класичні романи так
браво
дуже дякую Ольга класичний роман
давайте скажемо разом класичний роман класичний
роман дякую тому ми вже
вгадали всі слова, зараз давайте
їх запишемо візьміть аркуш паперу будьте готові
і ми збираємося написати  слова, то
одна дівчина, яку ми збираємося написати разом, добре, у
вас є золота сковорода, добре, так що один
два три чотири п'ять шість сім вісім дев'ять
я думаю, добре  їх буде дев’ять
слів, тож давайте розглянемо одне за одним, чи можете ви
сказати мені, що ви диктуєте нам, давайте почнемо
з пригодницьких пригод, тож давайте
запишемо дивні, коли вони є потенційним
прикладом війки, був останній
відмінок, який вона використала  щоб сказати мені, будь ласка,
запишіть слова в три рядки, і ви будете
впевнені в цьому слові назавжди
так багато людей кажуть Adventura на
мосту так, але правильний один -
пригода, тому, будь ласка, повторіть пригодницьку
пригоду фантастичне наступне водоросте
фентезі Браво  добре ура ура це
слово легко написати, але вам воно не подобається,
хто любить лякатися добре,
давайте перейдемо до
наступної наукової книги наукової книги
давайте добре перевіримо слово, будь ласка,
ми використовуємо дефіс тут не  художня
література документальна добре давайте з наступною
біографія біографія чи можу я привітати
свою вчительку англійської так, будь ласка, подивився
під вазеліном я так люблю
тебе, ти мій улюблений, і завдяки тобі тепер
я можу почувати себе впевнено зі своєю новою вчителькою
Наталією я можу  с  rove, що це
найкращий учень, давайте перейдемо до слова
номер шість,
давайте зробимо роман, добре, так давайте скажемо
разом роман роман
Браво, давайте продовжимо, що ще ви
бачите злочин Рілла Рілла кримінальний трилер
давайте запишемо
це подивіться у нас є два різних слова
злочин  трилер тримайся, що ще
ми бачимо, у нас є документальна література, що починається
з ранньої перевірки так,
велике спасибі фантастика наукова фантастика наукова фантастика
наукова фантастика добре та
останній класичні романи Браво,
твій улюблений, ага, як ти пам'ятаєш,
як  напишіть слово чи є у вас якісь
життєві обійми, мабуть, написання трьох
рядків - це дуже гарна техніка, щоб запам'ятати
це, або ви можете потренуватися з нашим улюбленим
розгадувачем головоломок, наприклад, я збираюся
писати слова дуже швидко, і ви вгадаєте,
Ольга, ви  буду моїм помічником. Я
написав це слово дуже швидко, і ти
намагайся його вгадати добре, FA і TAS, чому
не можна, це фантастика Bravo fic tion Bravo
um and o ve l and l ve L know L novo
дякую  дуже добре, давайте спробуємо
інше. H О, подвійна повія RoR,
добре, ви можете спробувати це по-іншому, ви
спробуєте написати це, і я збираюся здогадатися,
чому я OG r FY хороша біографія adve aunty
ти в пригодницькому романі молодець
аплодисменти добре зроблено, давайте
продовжимо Мені подобається ця гра, я думаю, що вона
дуже корисна для сучасних дітей
, тож давайте розглянемо всі
книги, ми збираємося вгадати, вони
подивіться це символ книги чи можете
ви вгадати книгу  Я впевнений, що
ви можете мені допомогти, тому що ви любите дитячі
книжки, це казки так,
який тхір
сміється дуже відома казка про
чарівника чи чарівника Гаррі
Поттера так, це так, я не впізнав його,
це  просто символ праворуч
символ книги, тому цей символ іде до книги про Гаррі
Поттера, а тепер я створив
для вас дуже складну вікторину, тож давайте подивимося, що в
різних книгах багато символів, і я хотів би, щоб ви
подумали про назву  книга не
тип книги, а  назва книги, як
ви бачили у чарівника, це була книга про Гаррі
Поттера,
наприклад, давайте подивимося на цей
символ, зоряні війни — це війна між дітьми
так, тож не поспішайте і спробуйте
вгадати книги, і Ольга зробить це
тут  Я вважаю, що у мене все чудово,
тож чи готові ви, давайте перевіримо разом, тож
коли ви хочете висловити свою думку
про книгу, ви можете використовувати ці фрази
, подивіться Я думаю, що це так,
наприклад, корона, ви бачите символ
корони  і ви можете сказати, я думаю, що це так,
і ви називаєте книгу, тож давайте з
іншою фразою це те саме
значення те саме, але ви можете просто сказати по-
іншому, я думаю, це можна спробувати,
Ольга, я думаю, що це я здогадуюсь
я вважаю, що це також можливо, якщо ви
вагаєтесь, і ви не впевнені, що можете сказати,
що я не впевнений, але я думаю, і ви здогадуєтесь,
і якщо ви на 100% впевнені, що ви знаєте це
досконало, ви можете сказати, що я впевнений, що це  наприклад, це
книга про Гаррі Поттера, тож давайте знову
повернемося
до книжок, я думаю, що я
вірю  Я не впевнений або я впевнений, давайте
підемо першу книгу Ольга, я впевнений, що
є Зоряні війни Браво
давайте перевіримо правильно, давайте з
наступною Я думаю, це корона О
Єлизавета, королева Єлизавета, королева
добре, дозвольте мені поставити все  ці книги на
дошці, тож ми вже згадували Зоряні
війни, добре, друга –
трохи королева, наступна, я впевнений, що це
Маленькі жінки,
Браво добре, Маленькі жінки також тут,
наступна, я не впевнений, але  Я думаю, що
це N і і і зелені глотки так
і Green Gables ще раз
і Green Gables так, відомий як
земля тут, це дуже популярно
серед дітей, а також,
ймовірно, це буде ваша наступна
книга, дякую  добре, давайте перейдемо до
наступного, ми вже обговорювали це,
що це знову я впевнений, що це
книга про Гаррі Поттера, так, помістіть її сюди
книги про Гаррі Поттера, а що щодо цієї, у
нас є петля, о, це я цілком
впевнений  як Шерлок Холмс
так Брауер пригоди оповідань про Шерлока
Холмса  фантастично, давайте з цим, у
нас є шматочок шоколаду. Я цілком
впевнений, що це "Чарлі і шоколадна
фабрика" так,
дуже дякую, добре, а наступний і
цей я думаю, що це символічні книги, багато
з яких  кільце так Володар перснів Браво
добре, тож у нас є всі книги тут і
на дошці, тож ти читав будь-яку з
цих книг Ольга, я читав, я читав Маленькі
жінки,
добре, я зараз читаю це був
подарунок на мій день народження  цього року
Єлизавета Королева це була книга, яку я купив п'ять
років тому в Лондоні королівська дівчина так, я
читав цю книгу, і вона була моєю улюбленою
під час моєї вагітності була моя дитина, яка шукала,
я прочитав одну частину Гаррі Портера добре,
ви знаєте, що я  не великий шанувальник фантастичних
книжок я не читав «Зоряні війни»
та книгу про них, ей, Шерлок Холмс,
звичайно, це моє щоденне читання, добре,
щоб бути моїм щоденним кільцем і книги докюн
ні, ні, тому що ти не великий шанувальник
фантастичної книги, що з
тобою так вливай у книги, які у тебе вже є
чи читайте або виберіть ті, які б ви
хотіли прочитати, добре, зараз ми збираємося
обговорити ці конкретні книги, давайте ще
раз ми збираємося використовувати ці
фрази, ви не можете побачити книги зараз, але
ви бачите фрази та  книги
будуть на дошці давайте розберемося
з типом книги я збираюся прочитати
короткий зміст книги спробуйте
вгадати назву книги та тип
книги добре один Бог допоможе мені тут
класну кімнату, а ви відповідайте на
запитання у себе вдома, давайте,
тому ця книга написана Джоном Ролінгом.
Це історія молодого чарівника та
його друзів, які борються проти темного
чаклунського органу, чи можете ви мені допомогти, я вважаю, що
це Гаррі Поттер,
добре і  що це за книга такого
типу у нас є детектив фентезі
біографія науково-фантастична література,
що ви думаєте, чи це класичний
роман наприклад це не класичний
роман Я не впевнений, але я думаю, що це
фантастична книга, можна сказати, що
це  книга фентезі пригодницька пригода
whi  ch one, ти віддаєш перевагу я думаю,
пригодницькі пригоди, давайте, так що ви
можете сказати, що книга про Гаррі Поттера — це
пригодницька книга, давайте продовжуємо, послухайте
мене, будь ласка, тому цю книгу написав
Артур Конан Дойл, історії
розслідує відомий детектив і
його  друже, ти можеш добре вгадати історію,
ти можеш мені допомогти. Я вірю, що це
Шерлок Холмс, добре, а
стиль чи тип книги, це детектив
або у вас немає нас так, я займаюся
детективами,
Торрі, так що ви можете сказати, я думаю, о
Я впевнений, що я впевнений, що це детектив, добре,
молодець, так що Шерлок Холмс фантастичний,
давайте з наступною
хммм, ця книга написана Люсі
Монтгомері, історія, сказана в кінці
19 століття, про 11-річну
сироту  дівчина, яка помиляється, послухайте
двох братів і сестер середнього віку, чи можете ви
вгадати книгу та книгу Green Gables,
фантастичне, велике дякую, і що
ви думаєте про жанр чи
тип книги, що залишилася
біографія так, це зараз класична і
whi  ch добре, дозвольте мені вказати це тут і про
Green Gables, добре, так що це класичний
роман, який допоміг вам вирішити, що
це класичний роман насправді
обкладинка книги, тому що вони можуть
бачити ціль у старомодній вікторіанській
сукні, добре і  Крім того, ця назва не
зовсім сучасна, а
Зелених фронтонів, так, як вони називали, це книги
сто років тому, як чоловіки, і послухайте
мене, історія розгортається наприкінці 19
століття, так, так що ми маємо згаданий час,
і ми можемо вирішити, що це
чи стара книга настільки класичний роман, що
добре, давайте розглянемо наступну так, і
коли грудь стане класичною,
це дуже цікаве питання, я думаю,
коли ми маємо визначення класичного
роману, це старі книги, але все
ще популярні, добре  отже, це стара
книга, але люди читають її і читають
знову і знову, і починають, тому вони називають
її класичним романом, дякую за
пояснення, що це не так, це не вмирає,
давайте виберемо це, ніби воно не
вмирає, добре, давайте  рухайся так  ця книга
написана Луїзою Мей Олкотт, історія
наслідує рядки багатьох сестер
Мак Джо Бест і Емі та детально описує їхній
перехід від дитинства до жіночого, чи можете
ви вгадати книгу чи жуйку Я впевнений, що
це книга для жінок
Жінки,
так, що це за книга, вона також
класична о так,
класичний роман, у нас це
фантастично, давайте рухатися далі, тому ця книга
написана Джоном Рональдом, розповідаючи, що історія
є продовженням Хоббіта
Більбо Беггінса, який знайшов кільце, я вважаю, що
це  Володар веселки Браво
і тип книги фентезі так,
велике дякую, все тут добре, так
що це один з моїх улюблених фільмів, хоча
я не читав книгу, але фільм
дуже популярний у моїй родині, а ви,
хм
добре, давайте рухатися далі, ця книга
написана лялькою Рональдом, історія розповідає
Пригоди хлопчика на
фабриці Віллі Вонка Я думаю, що це
Чарлі і шоколадна фабрика, бум
Браво,
що це за книжка проти ф  Антезі
Сахні дійство від вашого передайте це начебто
це може бути класичне звичайне ну може бути
але, на жаль, у нас є так Роальд
Даль він уже помер так, мийте його, вибачте,
але чи думали ви про історію, це
фантастичне фентезі, погодьтеся, тому що
це історія  від уяви походить
від уяви і показує шокуючу
уяву, дуже моторошний спосіб не тут
його, тому у нас залишилося лише дві книги, я
думаю, це буде легко. Ця книга
написана Джорджем Лукасом серія розповідає
про пригоди різних
персонажів  час тому в
далекій галактиці це, звичайно, я думаю, що
це книга «Зоряні війни», і це
наукова фантастика, як ви бачите, так, ви
бачили в фантастиці Браво,
тому, якщо ви пам'ятаєте науково-фантастичні книги
, це історії про космос
майбутнє у нас є слово «галактика», тому ми можемо
здогадатися, що це «Зоряні війни», і остання,
про яку ми прочитаємо Єлизавету Королеву,
тому її написала Саллі
Беделл Сміт і розмови про
життя  про всесвітньо відомого монарха,
то що це за книжки, що це за
біографічна біографія і ця
Єлизавета Королева, яка, звісно, замовляє ваше графіті, то
у є також дуже відомий фільм пр
це, він називається корона, то
у, мабуть, я вибрав для цього си
вол  забронюйте саму корону
, ви дивилися цей фільм так, я
справді з нетерпінням чекаю нового
сезону так, я теж,
де ми не можемо дочекатися
продовження, тож давайте перейдемо,
подивіться на цей уривок, тому Гаррі Поттер –
це пригодницька книга  написана Джоном
Роулінг, це історія молодого
чарівника та його друга, які борються
з темним чарівником, тому, якщо ви подивитеся на цей
конкретний параграф, у мене є різні
кольори, тож що означає зелена водорість, чи
можете ви мені допомогти, це назва
книги  так, спочатку ви почнете з
назви книги давайте подивимося
на блакитну на тип книги
чудова і давайте переглянемо у нас є романтичний
кримінальний трилер документальна література чи можете ви
мені допомогти Ольга детективи фантаст  asy біографія
автобіографія фентезі наука наука
фентезі пекло наукова фантастика наукова
фантастика сер фантастика фантастика фантастика
дуже дякую, так що давайте перейдемо до
червоного комірця що це таке
ім'я автора книги саме
той фіолетовий найбільший уривок,
але короткий  огляд цієї книги
пояснення, що таке книга про так,
короткий зміст або сюжет, лише речення, яке
описує книгу, добре, так що це про
книгу про Гаррі Поттера, чи можу я запитати вас
про книгу «Зоряні війни», чи можете ви
описати її, якщо не пам’ятаєте  Ви
можете призупинити перемотування відео назад,
подивитись ще раз і послухати моє пояснення,
і Ольга допоможе мені з цим, тож чи можете ви
розповісти нам про книгу «Зоряні війни» «Ольга», «
Зоряні війни», це наукова фантастика,
написана Джорджем Лукасом, і вона розповідає нам
про  минуле в майбутньому так, і це показує,
потім він показує уявний світ мм-хм,
який відбувся дуже давно, добре,
в майбутньому, вибачте, я думаю,
що я не дуже хороший пояснювач, вони кажуть це
я  ти можеш пояснити своїми словами, не
хвилюйся, читай цю книгу, все
добре, я збираюся запитати тебе про книгу,
яку ти зараз читаєш, давайте поговоримо
про маленьких жінок, вам буде
легше О, маленькі жінки, це
книга  написаний, він був написаний так, як сто
років тому, якщо класичний роман і йдеться
про чотирьох дівчат, чотирьох сестер,
чотирьох братів і сестер, які показують чотири
типи персонажів, а також переносить нас
із свого дитинства до їх жіночої статі,
і, на жаль, ми втрачаємо одного персонажа,
закладаємо так, але це так  не вікторіанський роман, який
ви знаєте, у кожному вікторіанському романі
має бути хтось померти так, це
просто сюжет, який нас цікавить,
і ви можете прочитати його насправді, так що
проти дуже хорошого різдвяного тарифу так,
і ви вже бачили фільм ні ні
ви можете подивитись це дуже гарний
фільм, особливо останній
найновіший ви дивилися цей фільм добре,
давайте далі, давайте подивимося на
цю книгу Єлизавета Королева, тож давайте
опишемо це бу  k так, Ольга, ви можете допомогти
мені порадувати Єлизавету Королеву, це
книжка, написана графічною книгою ealousness,
і вона описує життя
найвідомішої Мони в світі, і відповідно
до цієї книги у нас є прекрасний
фільм Netflix так, дуже дякую, а
little bit the queen - це книга біографії,
її написала Саллі Беделл Сміт, і
це історія про життя
всесвітньо відомої MONUC саме те, що ви
нам сказали, Лука, дуже дякую, тому
подивіться на свої домашні завдання, хлопці, я вас запитаю
щоб написати абзац до чотирьох
речень, будь ласка, більше не про дві книги, які
ми сьогодні обговорюємо,
тож давайте підсумуємо, давайте подивимося
на книжки Маленькі жінки Єлизавета
Королева наступна все, що ви можете, допоможіть
мені
Чарлі Шоколадна фабрика велика кількість для
багатьох їх  кільце Браво
Гаррі Портер і великий Гейблс Гейблс
фантастичні Зоряні війни та Шерлок Холмс
добре, так що знову серед цієї восьми,
яка буде улюбленою, дозвольте мені вгадати
маленькі жінки маленькі жінки зітхають улюбленими,
але  Я збираюся читати, а про
фантастичні Зелені фронтони, мабуть, пізніше ви
розповіте нам про цю історію добре,
мій улюблений, звичайно, Шерлок Холмс
зрозумілий Квінн. Я люблю читати
детективи та біографічні книги, тому
я чую, як дзвінок дзвонить, це означає, що нам
потрібно  щоб припинити урок, тобі
сподобався урок так, вони зробили це було
дуже весело, дуже дякую, дуже
дякую і дякую, що приєднався до нас
на уроці.
Lamia просочував
долар Claire Puttanesca на день, а також
супер їжу для карате було виготовлено в Самосі,
останній гуджараті, обробляючи будь-який bateau de
ponerse media coconut a yield image
дами туалет брудні солодощі манія
[Музика]
ви